yo today we're going to shoot a video
about superheroes fighting gaming heroes
as you can see I'm dressed up like
Master Chief stay tuned
you know like Steven Spielberg kind of
DreamWorks and that doesn't make movies
anymore you just like watches other
people make movies that's right that's
us no basically this fall we're putting
out a ton of videos since fall we
decided to work with Wren and obviously
have Jake produce and write pieces with
us the first time they've ever had
someone else direct one of their videos
for them so I'm honored
all right I am Hudson this is Brandon
and we are the buff dudes yeah we have
our own YouTube channel it's kind of
fitness and comedy not quite as crazy as
cord or digital so it's an honor to be a
part of their video and we're just
excited to have a roll
oh hi my name is Jake I'm from the
YouTube channel Vsauce 3
according to legendary pictures Godzilla
is 355 feet tall but it raises the
question is a creature of that scale
possible could Godzilla exist I think
it's a pretty good look I'm gonna go
with it it's really the shadowy I look
kind of brings out the color of my eyes
I would say what do you think so as you
guys may or may not know this is the DJI
Ronin and very recently uh we have
actually began a Content partnership
with DJI we've been using this stuff for
a long time Superman with the GoPro was
shot on a phantom 2 compared to the movi
which we've used in the past it's
actually a little bit better for our
uses because it's got a little bit of a
higher of like capacity for weight so
it's easier to load the red on - so
we're loving it so far and this is our
first shoot to test it out on all right
so good news this blood has zero
calories so if you're ever watching your
weight which I obviously am this is a
good thing to drink the entirety of this
piece is kind of like a spiritual
successor to you know the glitch help
and power table UK obviously like ran
with the direct thing he's been doing in
the past perfect fit for a style like
this so really looking forward to see
how this turns out
she's gonna get it right around and
dirty where'd you get that camera its
first none of the day a so we're near
doing shoots like this yeah it's cool to
get great shots but your primary focus
is always safety oh never want to hurt
anyone um and so when you're swinging
around you know a thirty pound hammer
like this you can crush a skull with it
you want to have some space so wait how
you shoot it is you just kind of add a
little bit of space compress the space a
little bit and just shoot it at an angle
where it looks like it hits even though
there's still a couple feet of space
there faster moving shots that's where
we have the replica Neill and their
hammer ah and that's where we actually
got the reverse shot where we just
filmed them like taking it down throwing
it away so in the Edit will be grabbing
it putting it up and then we cut
immediately into the next shot with the
beauty hammer ah see I can sing to
anything even when there's a little yawn
in my mouth yeah we are going to get the
last shot of the day which is a Ronan
shot of Thor getting caught by a
Pokeball
gotta catch'em all including Asgard's
finest so for this video we wanted to
have a Minecraft cave and since you
can't exactly go film a Minecraft cave
somewhere we decided to make our own we
had a few people literally spend two
days and paint this whole hallway here
and we got a brand in this little
Minecraft torch and voila here's we
actually lit this very interestingly
because it's the test wreck which is
very blue against these torches which
are in the game at least very very
orange that's a nice little color
contrast there so we decide to light it
with couple different LED panels one all
orange lighting this area here and a
strip of blue LEDs actually the Miko
head and use that as the tesseract light
and we're able to get some good color
contrast there banging away at the walls
in we have our intro answer for the
video
you